My, my, boom!
Hello, everybody.
I missed you guys!
Hi!
Welcome back.
I'm...
from my grand, grand adventure.
Holy moly.
It felt like...
forever!
Wow!
Thanks for all the memberships!
Oh, heyo!
Thank you!
Thank you, Daddy!
Wait, don't I pose like you!
Thank you!
The great epic return.
Does it get loud enough?
Wait.
My stuff is all over the place.
Where do I put my water bottle?
Over here!
Whoa!
Thank you guys!
It's green!
Everything is... It's green.
Welcome home!
Thank you!
Welcome back!
It was great getting to meet you at NYC.
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome back, Avito.
The concert was amazing.
Really love this song, you did it with Matara!
Yes, yes, yes!
Green.
Welcome back, boys.
Thank you!
Whoa!
Very late, thank you so much!
I was able to watch Skyline's Aeronade on streaming.
I love the choreography for your 10-10-10-10-5-5
performance!
Thank you!
Nimi and I...
We...
Nimi...
We like collaborated dance moves for that, but it was really
fun.
It was so fun!
I'm so glad we could do it live.
Like, crazy.
That'd be one year of Membushhip.
One year?
Thank you?
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
So for those who don't know, I was in Japan for about a
week.
I went to Comic Market, the famous, famous otaku event of
the ever.
Let's thank you so much for the hug!
Guys, super!
Welcome back, Amito!
Thank you!
my mama Ayami sensei she she was picked as one of the
artists for for the for the official ComiCat goods and she
decided to draw me along with her so my face was like oh in
a lot of places of ComiCat and it was pretty freaky it was
pretty freaky and so that we were in the vending machines
and And we were on bags and cakes and cups and so many
things.
It was super surreal.
It was so crazy.
It was so...
I was like...
I would see people wearing like the shirts or something.
I'd be like...
How is that my face?
How is that me?
How is...
And then, also, it's the 50th anniversary of Comic-Cat.
So, everything said, like, Comic-Cat 50th.
And I'm like, holy cow!
I'm part of such, like, a big...
You know, I feel like...
I mean, I really didn't do anything.
Because it's all because of my mama.
Asked me.
She's like, do you mind if I draw you?
With everything?
And I was like...
What do you mean?
Why would I say no?
So, yeah, crazy.
Like, Kamiyoshi is famous.
No, no.
But, hmm.
Yummy Mama really spoils you.
I think she does.
I feel bad.
I don't.
She spoils me too much.
Oh, she even bought me Unagi.
I love my mama No, I'm just really glad that You know You
know I explained this to other people too When I was When I
was 3.0 thinking Like, you know There were quite a few
artists I was considering Ultimately I'm really Of course
I'm so happy with Ayami mama Because she's also my friend
know and you know i could have gone with anybody else but i
think ayami mama treats me so well and like nothing else you
know baby court thank you awesome job big apple me too thank
you so much thank you thank you sounds like a great friend
yeah yeah want to support her more as much as she supports
me you know so and you know I've just been a big fan of hers
for so long too so it's just a you know full dream come true
but comic cat was so holy cow my gosh how
do I describe thank you magic sword king I turned 39 years
old today wanted to say the skyline serenade was the best
early participation a so King Kurobastor.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Fun, overwhelming.
It was both, fun and overwhelming, yes.
It was how hot was Kamiket this year.
I just describe it as wet.
And not because of the rain.
The torrential, the downpour that happened on day two.
But because The amount of sweat that I had.
My ectoplasm was quite everywhere.
Just, just.
My pants were wet.
My undies were wet.
My shirt was wet.
Everything was wet.
My, everything, my socks were wet.
It was just so sweaty.
So sweaty.
Everything.
was wet.
It was so...
Comic-Cat was so hot!
But I'm excited for Winter Comic-Cat too.
I'll be going.
I will also be going for Winter Comic-Cat.
And I think you guys should too, if you can make the trip
out.
I mean, Comic-Cat is like... It's a rite of passage for
being a no-time like I don't know there's just such an
energy about it being around so many other people that are
like just there to support the things that they love like
it's so I don't know how many Koharu cosplayers did you take
photos of I only saw one Koharu cosplayer and she was
working a booth so I got no photo of her sadly but it's one
of my dreams to go one day yes i mean definitely be prepared
because it is quite it is it is a when when people say it is
a battle it's like it is quite literally a hundred thousand
people packed into big site thank you so much for the
amazing concert thank you thank you jake i'm glad you ain't
discovered singing break stuff oh oh wow thank you that was
a while ago huh um what kind of battle well like the amount
of bodies there are is like so it's it's really hard to to
to describe like it is like it is so so gross like okay
sometimes in summer comic it will be so humid and sweaty and
disgusting that a cloud a literal cloud cloud will form
inside the hall like an actual cloud like and it is just
sweaty bodies like bouncing up against each other everybody
trying to get to their to the like circles that they're
trying to buy from like so it is it's it's it's this is my
first ever summer comic I've gone to winter comic at a
couple times before this is my first summer one and at some
point you just kind of were like I had to I had to like to
kind of like when I was literally like blocked by everybody
in the world like just you know you kind of move with the
crowd to like i had to like go into my mind palace and i was
like people are not wet from sweat no we are we are i am at
the beach and i am in the waves and and i was i was like yes
i am i am one with the ocean right now the wet the wetness i
feel is not from other bodies or myself no it is from the
peaceful, calming waves that I am...
That I am...
Oh.
Salty sea breeze, not BO.
I...
I would say that the BO is probably not as much of a problem
as you would expect, surprisingly.
Maybe I was just so used to it, I don't know.
You have a great way of phrasing things, but...
Honestly, the smell was not as bad.
Maybe I was a part of it, though.
Who knows?
But, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I...
My friend asked me.
She was like, can you try and get the Kaguya Hime book for
me?
Now, if you did not hear anything about the Kaguya Hime
book.
It was...
quite possibly like you know the Kagoyahime movie that came
out it they're the the animator like the anime they made
like an like a Otskare book for the animation team from
above the Kagoyahime movie and my friend was like could you
try and get it because I was like a little early because my
mama gave me a ticket which means I get to not have to wait
in the lines which is so so nice yes yes cosmic princess yes
yes yes yes yes and I was like well I'm gonna go to my
circles first I'll go to my like the booths that I want to
go to first because lines start before anybody comes in it's
kind of crazy ah yeah I have the VIP treatment but I have
had to wait in that line before I have I have I have Um,
but, uh...
Uh...
I was like, I'll go to my booths and then I will go to...
I will see if Kagoyahime book is possible.
Um, when I was lined up, like, just to give you context, the
event had not started yet.
I was already in line for a booth.
And the event had not... Nobody had been let in yet.
circle people and circle people are just people that have
their own booths you know and she texts me and she's like
never mind there is already a massive line it might actually
be probably one of the longest lines in comic-cat history
like crazy I went I went to Minyon I went to a couple people
and then I was going to kind Everybody that I first hit up
was in the East Hall and I had to go to the West Hall for
Kantoku.
And I was over there.
I was heading to the West Hall.
And I was walking.
Because Kamiket has like a couple different halls.
There's like...
There's East Hall, South Hall, West Hall.
I don't... Is there a North Hall?
I don't know.
But um...
If you're not a circle, you're a square.
there or be square truly oh no all the artists are also
otaku yeah yeah you're fighting everybody um yeah I don't
think I don't think I've been to the North Hall if there is
one um but I was going to West Hall and I hear this like a
bunch of people yelling, the line for Takoyaki, no, not what
was it?
Pancake Octopus is over here!
The line for pancake octopus is over here!
And I was unaware that pancake octopus was the name of the
circle for the Kaguyahime book.
I did not know that was the artist's name, I suppose.
And I was like, what kind of nasty octopus pancakes are they
selling?
And why is it so popular?
I was like, ew.
octopus pancakes everybody's wearing these octopus pancakes
and and i mean and it's a little bit longer because um i had
already gone to a couple circles and i look over and i see
just this like the longest line known in existence like
crazy crazy crazy stuff and i get to the front of kantoku
line and i look over to my right and that was the pancake
octopus and I was like this is the notorious Kaguya Hime
book I am right next to it I had no idea holy cow like
sounds kind of good to be honest maybe if that's your thing
I don't know but yeah I was like oh my gosh I'm still in
transfer from NYC get home safe get home safe It was like...
So then you cut 20,000 Otaku?
No!
I would never.
Okonomiaki, right?
Well, I guess if you consider that a pancake, but I'm
thinking of like...
Regular batter.
Put some blueberries in there.
I don't know.
But, uh...
Is that just Takoyaki?
Maybe, I don't know.
Takoyaki is...
That was a, I don't know.
That's not a pancake, right?
But yeah, it was, the Comic-Cat was absolutely nuts.
Again, if you go for summer, you must really prepare
yourself.
Fans, cooling sprays, towels, everything.
Anything to keep you cool.
Lots and lots of sports drink.
No.
Big flat Takoyaki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did you end up getting the fold, eh?
Will!
Okay, I got...
Okay.
Before she broke it already.
No, no, no, no!
Hold on.
Let me blow my nose.
I...
I gotta blow my nose.
So right now I have the Samsung Galaxy S23 Ultra.
That is my current phone.
Got it for a couple years.
I got it because I really like the camera on it.
And I like the stylus.
But recently my stylus has like stopped, not stopped
working, but it has been very glitchy.
like no how am I supposed to play meow tower like this
that's so sad and um yeah I can't doodle with a bad stylus
it's been like not like the the input has been really bad um
that's the software update is it really is it really but
also I was like the phone itself is too big for my hands and
I've been having quite a few hand issues recently I haven't
really talked about it because it's not important but my
recently my hands have been going numb I don't quite know
why and I've been having some like issues with like like
bending
my pinky and my thumbs has been painful um so uh i was like
i'm gonna try getting a smaller phone
um carpal tunnel time no i don't know i don't think so it
wouldn't happen in both hands at once right i think it's
like some nerve issues that i've been dealing with
So, I didn't want to talk about it.
I didn't want to, like, seem like I'm complaining, you know.
So, but I was like, the fold is such a good size and it's so
much lighter.
So, I'm going to try it out.
Um, I mean, it's much smaller when it's folded.
But I also, I also, here's my, okay, this is that, this is
going to, it's going to sound like copium, but please.
Hear me out.
Please complain to a doctor.
I will, I will, once I have insurance.
I will.
Could be nerve damage.
Honestly, that's what I'm currently thinking.
But, uh...
Um...
Um, I...
I, uh...
Uh...
Sorry, what was I saying?
Oh, I...
I was like, you know, if I want a new phone, first of all, I
got $700 off of the Fold 8, which is, I mean, the phone was
already very expensive, but I was like, that's a lot of
money off, so that's pretty good.
And then also, and then also, I was like, my phone is just
going to keep depreciating in value.
And right now it's annoying me because of the stylus.
And so I am also trading in my phone for another like $300
off.
So it is a very expensive phone.
But I really want the size of it.
So it is copium.
But phones have an expiration date these days.
Ah, I know.
Yeah, the phone is like...
The fold A is so expensive.
It's so, it's like, it's egregious, to be honest.
Honestly, I don't want to reward that kind of behavior.
But I also want to reward the size.
I want the size to sell well so that they make, so that more
phones see that people want that size and make cheaper
versions of it.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's like the size of a passport.
It's so nice.
So, yeah.
Anyway.
I also was very...
sad and I impulse bought it in the middle of the diet so
yeah many things happen to me getting this phone many things
many things happen many things crossed my mind I did
consider it a lot though I was like how can I justify this I
don't think I can justify it the stylist messed up one too
many times look I lost a star.
I lost a star in Meow Tower, and that was my 13th reason to
buy the Fold 8.
Spangu's hi!
Welcome back, make it lovely to see Dead Set 2 in concert,
and make it green, do you want to hear some of it
post-pandemic?
No, don't reward this behavior, please.
But thank you so much for the walker's over.
Yeah, I'm glad I could see you again.
Mm-hmm.
Losing a star makes me feel so stupid.
I know, I know!
I miss my Samsung S4 Mini.
I don't know if I ever...
I don't know if I know that one.
Victoria Roman, as PNG was so cool, the whole gang was here.
Yes!
We got to pick, like, you know, people that we wanted to
invite.
And I wanted really badly, you know, it was hard for Vicky
to do three.
3D.
It wasn't possible, unfortunately, but I was like, I really
want to do a song with Den Setsu.
So I invited Vicky for Triangle Dreamer.
Yeah, after Japan.
Let's see, I'm trying to think of anything else that
happened in Japan, but I'm trying to go in order.
Something really stupid happened.
I was... I did get to hang out with Vicky though in Japan,
which was really fun.
um but we hung out and then that same day we were hanging
out i was like hey i'm gonna go to an idol live tonight if
you want to come with it's gonna be a lot of fun um and she
was like yeah and then the day of she messaged me and she
was like hey by the way like i was looking at my ticket i
think i got the wrong one my ticket says not for the show
but it says early goods buying ticket i think i bought the
wrong thing and i was like oh no and then i was like wait i
sent you the same as me the one that i the same link that i
used and then i was like i went to my i went to my email and
i saw you uh you won the lottery for early goods buying and
i was like oh my god
so no we didn't get to go to the idol show because we didn't
we didn't have a ticket what even is that sometimes for idol
shows they will let you buy goods early but you have to
lottery for it it's actually ridiculous you two have the
worst concert luck together oh we were just saying that we
were like we both have to stop doing this because before
vicky and i before we were even den setzu vicky and i hung
out and we were going to go to a hollow live concert
together and we both imagined the wrong date together like
we are we keep doing this somehow we are so we we're we're
too silly together it's like but it ended up working out um
uh we went out to sizeria we had some other friends with us
as well and i got to introduce them to okay sizeria has oh
my gosh i think i'm gonna do a stream of this you guys but
i'm also scared well not scared i feel like people will
backseat too hard but anyway they have a find the
differences you know like you have the two images and it's
like the differences between the images 10 out 10 concert
with the photography again oh seymour i got your photos uh
oh oh the other photos uh legend anil thank you thank you oh
my gosh mr fighter oh thank you so much for the hug i love
to be a vibe watcher today boss i've got work late good luck
with the park i just want to say thank you for making this
one of my dearest summers ever everyone was
Thank you, thank you.
Hands going numb may not be our business.
But I wouldn't say it's that important.
Oh, well.
I don't know.
It happens like in the middle while I'm asleep, too.
I keep waking up in the middle of the night because my hands
are numb.
I don't know.
Whatever.
It's fine.
But, uh, yes.
So there's a spot the difference thing at Siseria.
But I'm telling you, it is so...
BS sometimes and I was right before like we started it I was
like you guys sometimes it is so silly the littlest things
that they do to make it the difference and then that one
ended up being like I had to look it up and I was like this
is this is what I mean this is what I mean
I had the note 10 for years oh I remember my notes yes yes
until the screen The same happened to me!
The same happened to me!
I missed my note.
Yeah, I actually still have it.
Yeah.
But, um...
One extra finger?
No, I wish it was that easy.
It will be, sometimes, there will be like, okay, there will
be a pole in one picture, and then the pole in the second
picture will be, like, a millimeter shorter.
Things like that, things like that.
yeah great job at the new york concert thank you thank you
but yeah vicky and i hung out we got to do some cool stuff
uh maybe you guys will see later um i think i have the note
eight i'd have to look it back up but yeah go to new york
flu flu flu boy more what more what i can't can't even say
the joke.
I'm like, boy, were my arms tired.
Um, flew in.
And it was like torrential downpour.
Oh my gosh.
It was, um, it was raining so hard.
Did you go to the GW bridge finally?
I didn't do like anything in New York, unfortunately,
besides the concert.
um free shower yeah yeah i was i was really hot on the plane
so getting like the the water was really nice the rain um
yeah kiki did have problems with the rain i i arrived at the
airport and i like boom radar thank you
Marina!
I love you!
Thank you, Wes.
Don't send money to me, please.
Please!
Thank you so much, though.
Thank you.
There were so many thunderstorms there last weekend.
The concert!
I don't want to say it was cursed, but...
It was definitely an uphill battle.
Um, for a lot of it.
Um...
Yeah.
But I remember landing and being told immediately they were
like, so Kiki's flight was cancelled and I was like, What?
Like, hello?
I was like, ah!
Poor Kiki got in like four hours before.
I know!
We all like, we were like standing by the door, we were
like, Where?
Kikihima!
Please, please!
Um...
Yeah.
That girl can't catch a break with travel.
I know!
Poor thing!
I felt so bad.
She came in.
Luckily, a lot of green rooms at these places have showers.
So she was able to take a shower.
She came from the airport straight to the theater.
She didn't even get to go to her hotel or anything.
Or do anything.
Like, the poor girl.
Like, she was such a sport.
She came in immediately and put on a heck of a show.
And, yeah.
Such a trooper.
Yeah, yeah.
It was really fun, though.
I was really happy to be able to hang out with everybody for
just a little bit at least, you know.
Danny was talking about what you did to her.
How I looked at her butt.
for wait what did i do i was asking to look at everybody's
butt i don't know what was up with me
i looked at danny's butt i don't know i asked to see cakey's
butt for some reason and nimmy's i don't remember why
for some reason yeah there was a reason i wouldn't just ask.
I want to just say, hey, show me your butt, baby girl.
No.
It was... It was a reason.
It was a reason.
I can't remember.
Um, yeah.
This theater, though, kind of crazy.
Like, it's actually kind of crazy how uh, famous the bacon
theater is.
Wait, hold on.
I took photos.
um they they were they had like photos on the wall of famous
people that were there like at the same elevator that we
were using um like uh tina faye tina faye i i just watched a
mean girls and jerry seinfeld and uh i
took more i thought
oh uh john oliver and seth meyers i was like whoa Danny can
be our third.
I'm back from Anime NYC for different concerts in four days.
It was wonderful hearing all you.
Hopefully tomorrow is work from home.
Get lots of rest, Nicholas!
Should have signed the elevator.
There was no room on it, I think.
Yeah, so many people.
I was like, whoa, this place is full of famous people.
And then VTubers.
Crazy.
I was like, whoa.
I was like, John Oliver, that guy played Toucan in Lion
King.
Why is that Neil with Seinfeld?
Kiki was so funny.
She was like, she was like, we have to go to the soup place
from Seinfeld.
She was like, we have to go.
I really wanted to go.
I asked Nimi about it because her and Nimi went, Kiki and
Nimi went.
And Nimi was like, they were very nice.
I was like, oh, so you did get soup.
Like, I imagine people go in there and, like, roleplay.
They're just like, no soup for you.
You know?
Yeah, just...
But she said that they were very nice and that they did get
soup.
So...
For anybody that doesn't know, there's like this episode of
Seinfeld.
They go to a soup store.
And the guy is like super...
He's like got these crazy strict rules.
And you like can't say anything or something.
And then...
Soup store.
What else am I supposed to...
to call it.
And they serve soup.
But anyway, the guy gets really mad at George signs of.
And then he goes, I'll shoot for you.
And so they have to like restaurant.
But it's like, I'll call it a soup cafe.
It's not really a restaurant.
It's like a soup cafe.
I like how like half the chat is saying no soup for you from
Seinfeld and half is being like why are you buying clothes
at the soup store I'm at soup people are quoting different
things
I'm at soup
there are so many words for.
For soup?
The old versus the new.
I didn't really, I was surprised that Kiki knew about it,
though, to be honest.
I was like, whoa, you know about Seinfeld?
Like that.
I watched all of Seinfeld like a couple years ago.
I like kind of binged it.
Thanks so much for the dentists of me in Korea.
I'm so glad we met.
Thank you for Yeah, thank you, Chocolate!
Thank you so much for Skyline.
I'm so glad you love the flower stands we all made for you.
Since I worked on Nimmies.
Yes!
Thank you!
I have pictures of all of them.
Seinfeld is pretty big.
I'd say it's still a funny show.
She watches too much TV.
She maybe does.
Wait, why?
The timing feels so random?
I don't know.
Sometimes I just get into the mood to like watch it's kind
of like how sometimes i'll just play a game that i've never
played before that's like really influential in the gaming
world you know that i've never played sometimes i just want
to watch a tv show that's been really influential that's
kind of why i watched like breaking bad recently too you
know if nimi got to see her flower stand she did she did i
was with her when she saw it We all saw it together.
Taking my final for my Class A CDO.
Big rig license.
Absence Mind, you got this.
You got this.
Watch Twin Peaks with us.
I really want to watch Twin Peaks.
You just want to get some culture in the veins.
Yeah, sometimes it's fun to know how things are.
Like, you know, things will be referenced and you would
never know unless you watched like you know something like
Seinfeld or you know things like that but yeah so the
concert was a lot of fun really happy I was able to perform
with everybody Matara and I debuted a new song set me free
so that was really fun having a super time with the
references Yeah!
Yeah!
The head bob you did with Nimi for Ten Ten.
Might have been the cutest thing ever.
Yeah!
We like really...
I feel like we cooked with that choreo.
But if only the chorus was like a TikTok dance, everything
else was our own doing.
Ponserie was such a great way to end the summer.
Thanks for coming to New York.
Thanks for coming to Watchers!
I'm really glad that I could say I feel like it's probably
like a rare chance to do that live, you know.
And then I got to do it with Kiki for Lion.
That was really fun.
So, yeah.
They can't cook.
They're a release date for the song.
I believe.
She's the one kind of spearheading it.
So...
Is it hard practicing choreo when you're a part?
It can be.
Um...
Sometimes though we like talk about what things we want to
do.
Like we were like, oh yeah, we'll learn the TikTok dance
part.
And then, you know, for this we'll maybe we could try this
idea.
And then we just kind of like practice like uh when we first
meet up things like that so yeah yeah yeah yeah so happy you
could perform with kiki me too me too
yeah so boom oh thank you everybody who came to the concert
thank you to everybody who watched the bot or anything so
yeah and then saturday i wanted to go to the zoo but I think
the dinner slash lunch I ate for before the show after the
show thank you love the distance and performance and
triangle dreamer so much jumping glad you are the ocean jump
thank you what
is HSA thank you though but I think I got sick from the
food.
I was, like, so nauseous the night, the day after the
concert.
And then Nimmy and Phoebe came and visited me that night,
Saturday night.
And Nimmy was like, I also got really sick.
So, after the concert.
as long as it's after the concert right even now my you know
when like your stomach like does that like squeezy thing
when like it's like feeling ill it's like doing the squeezy
thing right now even so thanks for giving us East Coast
there's a concert to remember of course thank you Deloran
yeah so my stomach hurts even right now
um yeah and i like i i don't know i was like i was so it was
so bad i was so nauseous and my head was hurting so bad and
that was making me more nauseous and i was like why am i i'm
already dead why do i deal with this stuff being dead is
also suffering because that's what being a ghost is is just
suffering but yeah i just i literally was just in bed all
day saturday i didn't get to do anything like steiner bought
so many tickets for broadway we were gonna go see hades town
i mean everybody else did except me because i was too sick
in bed so i just have to go back to new york and i was gonna
go to the botanical gardens because they had a moon and
cloud monkey monkey monkey monkey Thank you!
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky,
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky.
Where's the glitch?
I thank you!
I got this back from an insurance payment.
The company had to rework.
And I got off easy.
Let's go.
But also keep your money?
I almost said keep your monkey.
The council's insurance buddy, please go before your hands.
Actually become ghostly.
Thank you!
I will, I will!
It's a more recent issue, so I just haven't had time to go
to the doctors yet.
Keep your minke.
You're down with the sickness.
Yeah, pretty much.
So I didn't get to do anything.
I didn't get to explore New York or do nothing.
And then Sunday I left.
It was very anticlimactic.
bed and I watched Beyond the Leaf Factor Fiction all day and
slept.
That's literally all I did.
The monkey cannot be kept.
Yes, it can!
Shiver!
Thank you!
I hope you enjoyed our Skylight Flowers and I did so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Vicky was there too.
Yeah!
Really glad I could invite her.
Yeah.
So, hopefully we can do more shows and everything on the
East Coast.
Yes.
Going to NYC just to spend the day with Jonathan Franks.
At least you got to see 432 Avenue.
I did!
I saw a 432 Avenue building.
I saw it from my Uber back to the...
I was like, wow!
Oh my gosh, that's the building that sways.
a boat and rent is like $80,000 and the trash bags fall at
such a high velocity it's so tall that it sounds like a bomb
going off that's the building that's the building the
eyesore i saw it i saw it i thought you got banned from uber
oh i just say uber i meant you know i mean lift i am banned
from uber um it's uber is just easier to say Yeah.
But yeah, yeah, yeah.
People actually want to live there.
I don't think they do.
Because I don't think it's being lived in so much as much as
I thought it would be.
Thank you so much for the content, Rinto!
It was the experience of a lifetime getting to see how
perform and thank you so much for the autograph cards for
the Super VIPs.
Thank you for getting the Super VIP!
Yes!
You have to head out, Minto.
Thanks so much for a basic concert.
Wow, Blake, thank you!
Thank you, my first YouTuber concert ever.
Wow!
I was jumping so much that my knees were wrecked.
Oh, gosh.
Please, take care of your knees.
Using a rideshare app over a yellow taxi in New York is
culturally insensitive.
Skeletons, I have a literal photo of you packing VIP bags,
and I'm not afraid to use it.
Don't test me.
I see you in the...
I'm looking at it right now.
You and everybody else.
And the tons of bags that are on the floor.
I say it right there.
Interesting threat.
What did you do to get banned from Uber?
I don't know.
They won't let me use Uber Eats, they won't let me eat, they
won't let me use Uber.
I used Uber like three times back at AX, like 2018 or
something.
They want me to call to unban myself.
And I don't care.
I got banned from Uber for no reason, too, and didn't care
enough to call them to fix it.
Koro-kun, you are exactly like me.
I just don't care enough.
I just don't care.
Don't ban me for... I didn't do anything wrong.
Is it because I sat in the... I was my first time taking an
Uber, and I sat in the guy's front seat.
I didn't know that the etiquette was sit in the back seat.
Maybe he was so offended.
He reported me.
Who knows?
Fopaw, I know.
I committed the biggest no-no.
Banned for sitting shotgun.
It's okay, though.
I have Lyft.
There's other rideshare apps.
It's fine.
But, yeah.
I'm home now.
I'm so happy to be home.
Glad you didn't find my tweet when my friend thought you
were the girlfriend of Steiner?
In his defense, he's not in the VTuber space.
I really hate that.
Wait.
I really hate that that way.
How did that, how did that come across like that?
Wait.
Minto hated that.
For anybody, Steiner is my manager.
she's gonna die a second time oh my god though seriously
though i will i try to warn people about steiner i'm like
people will be like why are you so mean to him why you're so
mean to him i you bully him so much it makes me want to take
his side no it's because he is that much worse In person.
What's the deal?
It's time.
Bring him up all the time.
I don't even bring him up all the time.
I think you guys are obsessed with him more than me.
I'm not even obsessed with him.
I bet him he seems nice.
Happy that was your experience.
hate him lovingly or do we hate him derogatory I've been
asked before but if a couple times like people being like
for like you know when you talk about Steiner is it like you
know is that you're like is that really I was like yes
And also, people will be like, when you talk about, like,
you know, Matara.
When you talk about Matara, like, I know you hate her so
much.
Is that really?
And I'm like, what?
What?
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Thank you so much for the awesome.
Thank you for the amazing concert, Skylights, our name is so
fun.
I hope you can feel the crowd's energy.
Also, I hope you feel better soon traveling.
So much is exciting, but rough on the boy.
And fingers crossed, being.
home get let's get good rest thank you thank you thank you
so much that did i get raided thank you if i had a right if
i got a raid thank you so much have you ever rid one of
those robot waymos like the cars i tried once it's kind of a
curse story i don't um there was like there was like five of
us we were trying to ride the waymo uh we kind of packed in
there and the waymo got like one feet and then somebody got
on the phone and was like hey like you're not supposed to do
that you need to leave i just wanted to try it
my idea.
Yeah, I've met Matara too.
She seems nice.
Yeah, of course they seem nice at first.
Of course she'll seem nice at first.
And then you realize how insane she is.
That's the same thing.
When I warn people about about about Matara, it's the same
as when I got warned about Steiner.
You you meet them and you're like, oh, they're so nice.
And then you get to know them and you're like, OK, this
person might actually be insane.
Matara scares me.
She is like the most extroverted person you'll ever meet.
And it's terrifying.
It's terrifying.
Oh my gosh.
It's so scary.
She is, I believe it.
Still can't believe she convinced a random person to give
her a ride.
That's not even the worst of it.
There's parts of this, there's parts of stories I cannot
tell you.
Because I fear for her character.
Like, it's like, like, she's so scary.
That bad, huh?
Yeah, I'm protecting her reputation.
I'm at Minto.
She seems more insane than anyone It's still very nice.
Ayako, it's Piorine.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Sorry, I haven't been able to watch your streams lately.
Don't apologize for that.
I'm in the army now.
Currently going through AIT.
Basically college.
Whoa.
Good luck.
Thank you so much.
I once waited in line with my fiance's extrovert Classmate
she invited the people they were waiting in line with to
dinner with us.
They were nice people luckily and we had a good time But
about that's exactly what she this is exactly what she does
That's exactly what she does
I'm glad I was able to meet you guys at the iron mouse booth
Past diners have custom blade made blade gifts to you guys
If he didn't get them, that means he's hoarding them for
himself.
I think they're going to mail gifts and stuff.
So, no, I haven't received any.
He's hoarding it.
Yeah.
Start of a horror movie.
It doesn't sound too bad.
I don't think the thought of doing small talk with somebody
sounds...
You don't think that's not the worst thing ever?
I already got Harry Gatel 2 Holy cow, I'm scared.
New Yorkton, thank you!
Thank you for performing live in Skylight Zero and it was a
dream come true!
I teared up a little when he took the stage and I miss you
so much.
Thank you!
So beautiful here.
We're amazing out there.
Thank you for such a special day and so much, and we don't
love.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I'm glad I could perform it.
before the summer ends so can you guys believe it's like the
end of August I have so much well there's a few I'm like
less busy now because the big concert's over but but October
will be quite a busy month for me as well there's still more
actually that's happening coming up so yeah I'm excited I'm
I was too humid this year though so so humid so hot so humid
I'm ready for fall baby I'm ready for fall we have just less
than a month now or what's today about a month yeah about a
month now until fall begins wow wow and a little over a
month until my birthday Yay!
Yay!
Yeah.
Yes, it's us.
My birthday, I'm turning 90!
How many marriage proposals are cons this summer?
A few?
Boy, is there something special about a summer proposal?
What would you like for your birthday?
I want Sushi Not 90, 19 No, not 90 19 I wanna go out for
sushi Dinner or something
The stream is over already No, oh wow I've been yapping for
an hour, sorry
I'll join the game Sorry, I kept you happening My favorites,
thank you, ghost is back!
Refresh, kinda!
Kinda, yeah.
Really miss you, Kanye, and so much money in Japan!
Thank you, thank you!
I will get my hands checked out.
See, I didn't want to mention it.
I don't want to mention it.
Oh my goodness.
Hello, team!
It's been too long!
We'll keep yapping while I...
While I do everything.
I have to remember how to play this game.
let's see oh i've got eggs i've got eggs
good they haven't starved no they could never they're fine
they're fine scorching egg put in there wait incubation
complete didn't i put this one in a van worm well i'm you
Yeah, I wish I could have more stories for you guys from,
uh, what's it called?
From New York.
Even Japan, I feel like I was just kind of like, oh my gosh.
It was such a, everything was such a whirlwind, you know?
He's gone by eight is a good birthday present.
You're so right.
Also, we're just three days away from the Master Collection,
like Master Collection Part two for Metal Gear, like hello?
It's a good time to be...
To be me!
Why are the eggs taking so long?
Don't worry about it.
Okay, we've got some schematics.
Oh, I was gonna make this refined metal helm.
Unless, can I make it in here?
Everybody be chomping, chowing down?
Wait, do I have a large feed bag?
What's my feed bag?
Yeah, I do, I do.
Yeah, I'll ask.
I'll ask...
Oh, whoa.
I'll ask Doki to adjust it eventually.
Sorry, I always forget.
I always forget.
It's okay, though.
The eggs are not a huge priority.
You're playing Peace Walker for the first time.
Giving Vicky a run for her buddy on the Yafs.
Nah.
It ain't a competition.
Oh, refined ingot.
Wait.
How do I get that?
I don't remember.
Let's do some more... Oh, I don't have the big storage
thing.
I'm gonna see if I can unlock it.
Four plus coal.
Oh, a huge!
Refined metal armor!
Wait, I already have this though, so I'm not gonna, I'm not
gonna do it.
Large pale bed.
Wait, how many?
Okay, I was 16.
Oh, SMG!
Hello?
Okay.
Accumulator.
Whoa.
Maybe I should get the coal quarry then.
I can't remember it all.
I can't remember it all where, what I was...
Before this...
Wait, I was gonna unlock the...
storage thing the storage thing coal quarry is useful okay
i'll do it then um like last time i played you know oh here
we go storage container
no black lung for all the pals no it's literally like the
how the children are they crave it they crave it They love,
they love the mines.
They love the mines.
Here, I'll even make one.
We'll put it back here so it's, like, not so obvious that
we're putting them to work.
Wait, where is it?
Is this a coal quarry?
Oh, we need coal!
That's why we have the quarry to mine it.
How do I make...
How do I make it?
How do I make Kola?
Guys help.
What are a pal, but a less humanoid child?
You mine it!
But where?
Gotta mine it from the dungeons.
Alright, let's go dungeon hunting.
Let me make sure everything is good.
I have no ingots?
Now I do.
Oh.
The birthday?
It's my birthday on Sunday!
Mother Grace, happy birthday!
As a boys, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday with salutations!
May your skies day be blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Happy Boppy.
It's your birthday.
La la la la.
Happy Boppy.
Let's go sell this.
Yes.
What is this?
A visitor.
Wait, I'll keep that.
Who goes?
We can put these over too.
A visitor?
Merchant?
Mercenary bot?
Who are you?
Oh!
Sell...
Oh wait, I'm gonna sell this.
Wait.
Uh...
Sell?
Nice.
What you got?
What are you buying?
Or what are you selling?
What do you got?
Oh!
jiggly jelly yeah what perfect timing right oh yeah I kind
of want some armor rice like 11 of them mmm gel Roy's jolly
jelly whoa interesting has like stat boost and stuff pal
tamer bodyguard we got a mercenary local restaurateur.
Oh, yes.
Where is he going?
Are you going to walk into the water?
Look how cute my character is.
She's so buff and awesome.
What if you capture him?
Oops.
How do I...
It's like nothing ever happened.
Wait, how do I, oh, Q.
Oh, yes!
Yeah!
Yes!
Grilled chipkin!
Awesome!
Well, guys, okay, let's go find a dungeon, right?
Well, hold on.
I am level 37.
Put him in the base?
Will he like make food for everybody?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, your other buddy disappeared.
You don't know what to do.
You're lost.
You're without any guidance.
Yoink.
Try using a better sphere.
This is the best I can.
God.
Okay.
Ah!
Where did you come from?
Help!
Pals!
Pals help me!
Ah!
Oh my god.
I'm obstructing the public officials.
Anyway.
Why didn't nobody...
Nobody helped me.
Why didn't anybody help me?
Why?
Life in jail!
I was...
Look, he's still here!
I think he like legitimately...
I think he legitimately likes it.
Eggie.
Do you?
He's just still standing here.
How do we, let's see what we need to do to upgrade our base.
Build a weapon assembly line.
Do I have that?
Weapon assembly line.
Sphere?
Is he still guarding the other guy?
I don't, I don't quite know.
in 32 oh thank you oh there it is yes thank you thank you
all right let's see what it takes oh that's not what i meant
first weapon assembly line we need ingots and wooden boards
okay wait we got those we got those this is easy uh acquire
all this all right so put this in here and we just need wood
and that's so easy oh whoops
I've been traveling since Opka and I've met more than a
handful of people who said they got into idols in some way
because of you?
Watching you guys do Triangle Dreamer was so cathartic.
Amazing way to end my trip.
Oh, no.
What the heck?
Because of me?
I just think that girls are cute.
Yeah, anyone else agree?
Anyone else say girl cute?
Anyone else agree?
I don't know like idols
they just like
it's like so different from just like a music group for me
there's like something about it like about liking idols and
supporting idols you know the whole journey of it all is so
like meaningful and you know I go to idolize you go to
idolize and you really see it this all the time but i'm like
man i like you know we're thinking all the time just like
and like so many other people see it too that like idols
work so hard and i it always inspires me to work harder
because i see how hard idols work and i'm like i'm not
working hard enough
yeah being japan a bit i don't think so i don't think so i
mean i will say that like idol music has like a great like a
lot of whimsy to it which is really nice that like I guess
you don't get from oh no now I need nails like you don't get
so much from other music sometimes so maybe that is like a
thing Japan moment
well I have enough 10 ingots yes meat
M-M-M-M-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I-M-I'm
into.
I mean, it's just music, right?
That's all it is.
It's music and a kind of community.
Music and community.
And it's nice.
It's really just nice.
Okay, I'm gonna put it here.
build build my pets my pals
community part is so critical i think so too and also i love
putting all of my like energy into obsessing and being
parasocial about about my oji Is that bad?
This is so bad.
How parasocial I am.
Alright, let's upgrade our base.
Yeah, baby!
Oh, summoning altar?
And sphere assembly line 2.
Which is this one then?
Is this one?
Sphere assembly line 1?
Oh, we need a better one.
Interesting.
Okay.
Let's add our new member of the team.
Ah!
What did I do?
Oh, I added him.
Wait, no.
Stay.
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to name him.
How do I name you?
Oh, details.
There we go.
Everybody welcome.
Sam.
me everyone welcome Sammy all right Sammy get to work he's
gotta cut what they doing hey Sammy Sammy Sammy Sam Samuel
oh meow cat we got to put me out cat in here oh yeah because
we defeated them
Meow cat must join.
You can still trade with him, right?
You can, you can.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's awesome, right?
Yeah, you can still buy and sell.
It's so good.
Pals without pal beds will get stressed.
He's gonna get stressed.
Don't be stressed.
I'll build you something right now.
Pal.
who's getting this big bed who the hell is meowing oh my god
let's hope this guy doesn't disappear like the last merchant
i don't look he's doing a good job yes yes yes sorry i'll
stop meowing
Aw, yeah.
Go, Sammy.
Go.
Swing that hammer, Sammy.
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Your hands have been hardened by the kitchen.
Ooh.
Someone's living in luxury.
Roo!
Thank you for the hugus.
It was a cool concert.
Was that your first time firing a beam at us?
I don't remember getting Minto beamed before.
I don't think I've done a beat- I don't know.
I feel like I've done some, you know, I've done on stream,
you know, like beams kind of, but that sort of beam might
have been my first.
What's he doing?
What is he doing?
What are you doing?
Sammy, his current task is kindling.
There's nothing there.
Okay, the game is a little, um, a little funny.
because uh currently combat is mining our home but we're not
gonna worry about it we're not gonna worry about it we are
going to go to a place on the map and we're gonna just
search for dungeons because we need coal coal coal we could
probably take on this blaze howl maybe we do that maybe we
do that I'm talking but I saw that tweet.
Did I say it right?
You ate the cookie inside the iBoo.
That, that was the tweet that I made of me.
Me eating.
Lucky.
Seeing the iBoo was actually, um, that was one of the cakes
from, from Comiket.
It was a chiffon cake from Comiket.
It was very, very delicious.
It's actually so yummy.
I wish I could have given them to you guys.
Yeah.
Good job, Mio Cut.
Good job.
Take over.
Nice.
Lucky, lucky, lucky.
It was like a chiffon cake, but it was, um...
How do you say?
Uh...
It's like ice cream flavored.
It was really good.
It was so good.
Oh, this is where one of those wandering things are, right?
I'm not going to call it cannibalism.
It's not.
It was a cake.
Hmm.
Yeah, like a vanilla ice cream flavor.
Oh, it was really, really good.
It was really, really good.
I wish I...
Well, I did request like...
Oh, hello.
Did we get this guy already?
No, there's no checkmark by him.
So no.
Blaze howl.
Does Catava have water?
I can't remember.
No.
Eggie has water.
Oh, he's sleeping.
He's sleeping.
All right, let's get him, Eggie.
Go!
Oh, nice.
Oh, yeah.
He just woke up.
He has no idea what's happening.
Let's try.
He was napping.
First try.
I guess I should go back to, like, Gigosphere or something.
I have a lot.
of these yippee is it possible to get some
some i guess not chip coal in here i did i did request a lot
of items from comic cat um i want to do a raffle and so
hopefully somebody i think i asked for some cakes i cannot
remember but hopefully some people can get Ibu Flavor!
Yoni mo- Nata!
Hopefully, if I- I can't remember, but if they did include
some, hopefully some people can include them.
I'm hungry.
Oh, because I died, that's right.
Oops.
Here, actually, we'll do that.
And there's a lot in there, so you should share.
Hoping I can get the tapestry.
Yes, yes.
Okay, let's go find a dungeon.
If I were a dungeon, where would I be?
I didn't get the tapestry.
I ended up buying for myself.
I bought the dogen bag.
You, like, put your favorite dogenci in there.
And I got...
I got, like, so many boxes.
bottles of water, but that was just for, like, actual
hydration.
And I got, um...
You got the Bleach Gamer Subs, you remember, use code
Boomer?
Thank you!
What else did I get?
I got the bag, like, the giant bag that they had.
You don't really need dungeons for coal.
It spawns as black-colored ores in desert or volcanic areas.
Oh, okay, I see.
Okay.
Then we need to go somewhere else.
Have I been to the desert before?
Kind of.
This area, right?
Or this area?
No.
This is that desert.
That's the desert.
Dungeon spotted.
I don't think it's open, unfortunately.
I have been to the volcano, but that's a really scary area.
That's the golden forest.
This is the golden forest?
No, this is the desert.
Who's dying?
Wait?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Anubis dunes!
Wait, maybe I do need to go here.
Wait, I think I do need to go here.
I'm afraid of this area.
We'll go to this.
This is much smaller.
Well, they're just killing everybody.
There's definitely some in Anubis Dunes.
Okay, I'll have some.
Let me ride you, Eggie.
Uh...
Am I going towards it?
Yes, okay, perfect.
Eggie!
Jump!
The big desert is near the hound you fought.
Just go up the stream.
Yeah, that's where we're going.
Awesome, awesome.
What's this place?
Whoa.
What's here?
What is this place?
Yoink.
Picked up a letter penned in crude handwriting.
Can I go in?
Sparkly fish.
Hello.
goodness a pal tamer did you come here to capture new ones
for your team in that case you might want to head to the
sandy area to the northeast it's rich in ores and minerals
and pals who like those sort of things some of them are even
happy to lend a paw or claw with the mining if you can tame
them good luck do you realize that you are living in a gold
mine here
we got this
high quality quality bait.
Let's go!
Yes, I don't remember how to do it, actually.
Oh, this
is easy.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go!
Oh, it's a turticle again.
I keep getting these guys.
Close call, I know, right?
Jeez.
Jeez, Louise.
come sparkle fish I think it's another turticle though
what was that what was that what's going on behind me what's
going on behind me I was scared
there was definitely a lot of sound happening was it this
cog me to oh oh Oh, maybe these guys?
Maybe those guys?
Just living in these...
Have you ever thought about living in these kinds of
environments?
Like, you know, like, Pokemon 2 and everything?
Like...
It feels like it would be so stressful.
I don't know.
Like...
Like, birds are breathing fire and everything.
Like, it's just kind of insane, no?
Just noise-proof the walls.
I just can't imagine.
It would be so much.
It would be so scary.
Am I headed the right way east?
Yeah.
At least you wouldn't get bored.
That's so true.
Probably not, huh?
Ow!
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Run.
Eggie, get out of here.
Chill out, Herbal.
Alright, we're looking for...
We're looking for...
Oh, is this some?
Over there?
Over yonder?
Twilight dudes.
This looks like some stuff, right?
Yes!
We got it!
Yeah!
The green birds are psychos.
Okay, good to know.
Thank you for the warning.
We need a lot of coal.
Oh, that guy looks spooky too.
Yeah, I feel like insurance costs would be like through the
roof.
I would just be so scared of like some giant creature
destroying my home every day.
Even bigger desert pass than Nubis Dunes.
Oh, well.
We got a good amount just to get started here, though.
At the very least.
Let's use my points.
I'm going to do more stamina.
Or wait.
Did I say I would do more stamina?
I can't remember.
Oh, let's do more weight.
It's kind of nice to have.
And let's go over yonder.
Up there, I see it.
But this we can at least get home and build the stuff that
we want.
You would dread living in a Spider-Man Super...
Yes!
It's the same exact thing!
No!
Like living in any sort of like superhero world is very
similar to like living in one of these.
we're just like oh my gosh no today's today's some dang
superhero took over my house living in Gotham that's just
New York I think oh oops I did the wrong one that's okay I
was talking about it with some friends like I feel to be to
live in like a city of like new york caliber or los angeles
or something like you really just need to be an extrovert to
a to a certain extent like because extroverts like have less
anxiety than people you know what i mean which is how
they're able to be so like you know outgoing with people
and like you just kind of have to like
just kind of have to like just oh i don't even know i don't
even know i could i don't think i could ever do it i can't
see myself ever doing it okay cool quarry where our place is
getting a little full huh our space management is not ideal
but whatever
good to have that friend or skill you might be amazed how
fast you can you could adapt you think so i don't know i
don't think i'm tough enough for it if you want to thrive in
la then being extra extroverted is a must but you can live
comfortably being an introvert i don't mean like no intro i
mean obviously there's gonna be introverts that live in big
cities i don't think i'm strong enough oh i don't want to
work i just don't think i'm strong enough all right how to
make refined
or maybe over here extroverts have less anxiety than people
mint phantom 2026 jokes aside as a fellow introvert i hear
you i feel like that's how it is though no am i crazy they
just have like a certain level of being like i can talk to
anybody i can just i can you know just like go up to someone
and ask a question just like i can just go outside my house
and be like la la la like i think it's a certain level i
think that's what makes like of extrovert they have no fear
they have less fear less anxiety about stuff yeah different
anxiety yeah true i'm not trying to say they have no anxiety
what do i make
The refined ingot.
I'm going to put the human guy on, uh, we're going to put
him on the, uh, the coal.
Where is he?
Wait, where is it?
Sphere, production mine, weapon, sphere, oh, ore mining,
there it is.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Yeah.
You need improved furnace.
Oh, thank you.
All right.
What is this?
Oh!
I have the improved furnace.
Okay, it's here.
All right, baby.
All right.
Do your thing.
do your thing do your thing oh you're on the primitive one
that's why get you off of that improved do your thing yeah
extroverts gain energy from social situations i have a few
extrovert friends who still struggle i i i just i i did not
express myself correctly i like i said i'm not saying that
that extroverts don't have anxiety at all like like yeah
they're gonna have different types of anxiety but like you
know introverts i feel like at least with my type of
introvertism it's like i feel anxious talking to people
fellas it was a joke yeah she just hates extroverts
extroverts scare me people are scary and being able to talk
to people Superman fighting kaiju's while Batman breaking
bone of teens who stole this.
Wait, what?
Batman?
Batman's going after the Joker.
What are you talking about?
My social battery has lasted longer with the jobs I've had
with coworkers.
Couldn't imagine how quick I'd lose it with other talkative
jobs.
I fear for the day I have to get a job normal.
Where it's like I'm just talking to people.
My social skills are like nothing anymore.
Uh-oh.
I'm in trouble.
Sphere Assembly Line 2.
Let's see.
Ore mining site.
Is that like every ore known to man?
Aquatic Construction Kit.
Oh, a kit that allows foundation to be placed on water.
Ooh.
I kind of want the mega grappling gun.
Maybe I should just go for it finally.
Air dash boots.
Woo!
You like orbs?
Name every orb.
Round.
Blue.
Yellow.
Red.
There's gotta be a purple orb.
Oh, deluxe bait!
Oh, yeah.
yeah that's some deluxe bait right there we need oh no wait
pal surgery table oh you can change what i was like what are
they are they like gotta get their tonsils taken out
anti-real job fun p.s i miss you so much thank you i miss
you guys
I'm an introvert who sometimes desires the company of
others, but I have a small social battery that burns out
quickly.
I'm very similar.
You need VR goggles that make people look like chat.
Gosh.
I'm too far gone.
Tiranzo!
Thank you so much for that, because I'm fun!
Welcome back, Vito.
I hope you had fun in Japan and NYC.
Also, I was driving home and couldn't type, but I cut some
nerves in my hand a while ago, and now when I pinched my
thumb and index finger, together for a minute or two my hand
also goes numb oh no oh no tv table trade thank you so much
for the second third i mean i just got back from my retail
doorb please don't get a doorb oh two oh two oh two oh two
oh two production assembly line two now where's the sphere
assembly line too
Is it that far away?
Oh, this is messed up.
The road sign.
No, pals allowed.
Oh, my gosh.
A steel armor.
Oh, there.
This ultimate sphere is a little boyful.
Search it.
Oh, you're so right.
Uh, what was it?
Sphere.
Advanced sphere assembly line.
Sphere assembly line, too.
Oh, I have it.
have it okay cool should I just get rid of this then I mean
huh we don't need it right this assembly okay sphere
assembly line two that's pal no production
oh I need a lot of stuff oh wow oh wow okay so we need that
and what's the other thing we need summoning altar yeah it's
expensive this guy makes stuff not make anything right now
you getting all that good old coal oh my god he sucks sam
you haven't even gotten a single coal you haven't done one
coal he did it circuit boards require oh my gosh it's one
thing after another
one should you put back the assembly line you tore down
maybe not the weapons
so funny story I don't have a sphere assembly line unlocked
so I have to unlock that first sphere assembly line and a
summoning altar.
Summoning altar.
Offer a slab depicting a pal to summon a powerful pal.
That's a lot of all my ancient tech points.
Just starting my last year of college.
I'm looking forward to getting a real job later and talking
to people I don't know.
Dilboop, you've got this.
I'm just weak.
Don't use me as a baseline.
I'm just a baby.
But everybody else can do it, I know it, I know it.
Oh, it's like crookin'.
You see that?
Alright.
How's assemble?
Nice.
Yes, use it.
Look at the tiny little hammers that they have to hold in
their giant hands.
Look how teeny tiny they are.
Teeny, teen, teen, teen.
Why is it?
Why does Incineram have a properly sized hammer?
Yeah, it's like they're swinging toothpicks, for real.
All right, we rebuilt that.
What does the summoning circle cost?
Uh.
What would it be under?
How?
Oh, here we go.
Whoa, we can do it.
We can do it.
Wait, can I just summon?
Wait, can I?
Oh.
This thing is humongous.
Maybe I'll put it up.
Question.
If I put an item or put a structure at the other base, does
it still count towards this base?
Build a platform for it.
You're usually building somewhere remote.
Well, um...
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky.
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky,
Minky, Minky.
Thank you for stashing in a Roth IRA.
Stop, you sound like my mom.
So you can just retire after the Mid-Fantom project
concludes.
Thank you.
You can tear it down after getting the base upgrade.
Oh, good plan, good plan.
under pal this thing is ginormous
overlaps you can assemble everything at the other base and
then move when you're you need here after upgrading
like it won't let me place it anywhere kind of tough okay
let's see if i build a foundation so we just need to build
up is that what you're telling me oh I don't have enough
materials
yeah skyscraper time yeah maybe I build it like was it wood
like was it the maybe I can build it, like, off the top of
here.
Yeah, yeah, you guys are...
Oh, 35 hours.
Well, I'll talk to Doki eventually.
About, um...
Yep.
Oh.
Wow.
Nice shot.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
From here.
Doki knows she forgot.
Yeah, that tracks.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Yes.
Oh, nice, nice.
It's like Fortnite.
Okay.
Some people are going to hate that comparison.
What do you mean not enough support?
number one victory royale yeah fortnite we about to get down
get down 10 kills on the board right now just wiped out
tomato town my friend just got down i revived him now we're
headed southbound remember when like fortnite was so simple
take me to your xbox and play fortnite today just wrap
around wrap above the egg building instead of providing
support like here you
can take me to moist my ear but not a little thing I'd
really love to chung chung with you we can be pro fortnight
gamers oh I have to delete these things ha oh wait it's a
disassembly oh Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Grab it?
Oops.
Wonderful singing.
Aww, thanks.
Okay, maybe this is enough.
I'm sorry, Nimi.
I'm destroying your house.
Let's try it.
I lied.
More.
It's always gonna hate it.
No!
Insufficient materials!
Yeah!
I'm afraid to see what it looks like.
Oh, completed!
What's that?
Ancient POW manuscript.
Ripped.
How am I supposed to get up here?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I might have locked myself out.
Wait.
Hold on.
Built like a staircase right here.
here
come on
wait there we go now anybody can use it uh oh build
that is horrendous uh that's not really nice to say that
about your mom
your mom built us
No!
Okay, wait.
We might be able to do this.
Wood.
We need more wood.
You're not my mom.
The slanted roof beds might be...
You think that's what it is?
No.
Wait, though.
We can make this work!
I just believe!
Just believe!
I can make this work!
Um...
I don't know what I'm destroying right now.
I'm so sorry, Nimi.
I don't know what I just destroyed!
I don't know my own strength.
What else does it need?
Oh wait!
Oh wait, there's another one right here.
All floors must be touching the ground.
I think you guys baited me.
Yes!
Luckily it doesn't take too long.
Wow!
Oh yeah, everybody's got a summoning altar on their rooftop.
Oh yeah, guys.
Oh, it's an open-air concept now.
It says level 35, but it's a lot harder.
Okay, okay, good to know.
Seems cold.
How?
Oh my gosh, it says 70 hours.
Damn.
I got it.
I took a little nap today, but...
like 4 a.m.
I went to sleep at like one and then I was up at 4 a.m.
and then I took like an hour nap earlier.
We're okay though.
We're good.
I'm sorry everybody.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
All right.
We've got refined ingots.
We can make that thing.
That I want to make.
The refined helmet.
Wherever you are.
It's modern.
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
What is a metal bat?
Fine ingots.
It's so refined.
You don't even, you don't, you don't.
wouldn't even I wouldn't understand it's too refined for
your tastes um I wonder do I make it here let's see um no
posh ingots is it over here
what oh I need 30 of them okay
arm unfortunately I do a better job than Sammy I don't feel
like working though so we're gonna go teleport back to this
area and we will do it we'll just mine some more until we
find until we have someone with better mining now sammy's a
bit of a disappointment it's okay yeah sammy has delicate
chef hands i i was a fool for thinking that he could be up
to the task you know what are you
whoa who are you oh no you know did you ever have like an
egypt era you know what i mean You're like, oh my gosh,
you're seeing like, you know, you had like your, when you
were obsessed with Egypt.
I see it like that.
Whoa!
Hello.
Oh, Eki, help!
Love vendor.
Oh, this is, this is the thing that once attacked our base.
I remember.
Yeah, I'm seeing that guy.
Oh my gosh, level 55 and new base.
I think I need him, I need him, I need him.
Yeah, I had that, you know, everybody, everybody, I feel
like had an Egypt phase in, like, elementary school.
And seeing that, like, really, you know, this guy really,
like, sparks it.
You can take him!
He's level 55!
What are you talking?
You would have seen me suffer and die.
Hello?
What's up?
You're scaring me.
I think she's in love with me, though.
She does, like, a...
Kind of pose, you know what I mean?
I didn't mean to kill you, though.
Not bad.
Hide the evidence.
Don't do it.
My friend is 28, and she's still in that phase.
I mean, can you blame a girl?
I had, like, the books that would be, like, learn how to
read hieroglyphics.
I was like, yeah.
I can read symbols.
Do I know?
Two times two?
No.
Can I tell you the whole hieroglyphic alphabet?
Absolutely.
My priorities, okay?
What is this?
Whoa.
Oh, it's this thing!
Anubis is awesome.
I'm gonna get him.
He's mine.
Perfectly aligned priorities.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh.
That doesn't quite work now, does it?
Oh, yeah!
Take it.
Natural-born linguist.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
Two?
Oh, you could shoot it?
Oh, well, I was way cooler.
Don't worry.
it oh wait i might actually need to for this guy wait do i
have a gun i think i have this one
i'm out of ammo uh the shooting it really work
is it this just terrible gun my makeshift shotgun has um
it's a shotgun yeah and he told me to shoot it
Let's get close and personal.
How close does the shotgun need to be?
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, I'm actually out of ammo now.
Okay.
We got a super style on it.
Oh, shoot.
See, we're fine.
Oh, that guy's dead in the water.
Those ology books were always at book fairs.
They were so cool.
I know, right?
Yeah, not even a problem.
We're fine.
Heat resistant metal armor.
Welcome back, me too.
I hope your trip was at least somewhat refreshing despite
getting sick in New York.
While you were gone, I went back to school part-time.
I'm going to be mad busy between work, but I'm excited.
School bugator, good luck.
with everything.
What the heck is that?
Toco-toco.
Didn't somebody say those guys were crazy though?
Maybe I don't want them.
Toco-toco.
Oh, there's a thing over there too.
There's a thing right there too!
Oh my gosh, he's taking a swim.
He's so cute.
Alright.
Well, coal.
Coal was our goal.
There's coal up here, I remember seeing it.
These birds are crazy.
They didn't even see me.
They're crazy, but I think they're blind.
There we go.
Coal is the goal.
Over here.
Where there's a coal, there's a goal.
Howdy boss, have you had fun in Japan and New York?
Love seeing you at Club Iron Mouse!
Yeah!
I was also at Club Iron Mouse.
You're a mouse singing, good luck, babe.
It's been stuck in my head on repeat.
I'll go back to Lurk Eggdale.
Thank you!
No big egg?
I don't know.
It's okay right for right now.
Yeah!
I also sang a club Iron Mouse.
You sang a song?
I have to like learn a little bit of Korean for it.
Yeah!
Yeah,
no, no, no, no,
no.
I'd be like, mohe, mohe!
Oh, no!
Okay, how much coal I got.
Wow!
Okay, we're good.
Uh-oh.
Take me home!
Oh, Eggie, you're just as slow as I am.
Oh, boy.
Eggie, I need you to pick up the pace, buddy.
Minky leaks.
No?
No.
already happened.
I'm over-encumbered.
Yeah, because I'm greedy.
I'm greedy!
Oh, let's use that.
On...
Yeah, I don't want to touch that fish.
It's all the way up there, though, if I want to...
Teleport.
Oh.
I know this.
It looks so cool, though.
Don't look at me.
I've got too much stuff.
Island Terran, it was so awesome.
I was my first VTuber concert.
I had so much fun with I was at the zoo in the new team.
David, darling!
Thank you!
Wait, it is right here, right?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's right up here.
Oh, I can't even jump.
Okay, it's all over.
I have to.
I have to get up.
get rid of stuff.
Take half and drop it.
We'll come back for it.
I was going to, like, drop it up there if I needed to,
but...
Oh, could I grapple?
Oh, you're so right.
You guys are so right.
Oh, wait.
Yoink.
Let's try.
Where's my grapple?
Right here.
Yes.
three oh four three two one
yes yes yes it is right here right i sure hope i'm in the
right spot
i'm in the wrong spot where is it oh it's over there I'm
messed up.
Guys, I'm messed up.
It's fine.
I'm here.
Okay.
I did this exact same thing.
Alright.
We're gonna make so much refined ingots.
We won't even know what to do with ourselves.
Except we have many things that we need refined ingots for
so we will know what to do with ourselves out of the way
everybody out of the way he's waiting for refined ingots boy
do i have the workload for you pal nice y'all how much is it
to make the new graph wait i think i don't have enough
ancient technology because I did the summoning altar I
sacrificed to my points so that I could have the altar
instead of the new grappling oh wait I just saw it
I guess we gotta go do more wait where is it actually
we gotta go do more dungeons
oh here it is the mega one yeah
Sammy oh my god Sammy how many coals have you made one
um is there an easy way to see who's good at mining coal
is there a good way to see who could be the number one coal
miner of the world he's doing his best he is whoa this guy
has three you can sort sort by mining sort oh this guy's
five this guy's five goodbye Sammy
yeah how will the mines go he's just kicking it no way he He
just kicks it.
He also put multiple coal miners.
Yeah, but everyone else kind of seems to be doing their own
thing.
Well, kind of.
What are you doing?
You know?
Some of them aren't doing their thing.
Oh, he's eating.
You're...
You're not being a valuable resource.
Have you seen the newest Meow Tower cat and completed their
story?
There was a specific moment that reminded me of you.
uh what was it the the summer cat um i did complete their
story was it moolo
mellow mellow so cute
mining for the second base oh yeah that would be good idea
too right look at him kick It's so funny.
How many more do I need?
To get my head thing.
Six more.
Okay, it's not that bad.
It's not that bad.
I think, though, there was something else that needed
refined ores.
Oh, I think it was the, uh...
This.
Oh, sphere assembly line too.
Do you have a chance to see some of the new students in
JPBA?
I really like the pink-haired Jidaike girl.
I think her name is Karen.
Is she Jidaike?
Wait, like the, like the diving club girls?
I saw like the Orca girl and the Beluga girl.
They're so cute.
Wait, there's a Jiraike girl?
Yeah, you need a hundred.
I know, it's craziness.
Right now, we're just gonna make our own helmet and then...
No, Gehenna.
Wait.
Maybe I didn't then.
My Twitter feed is so all over the place.
Sad.
Wait, what's her name?
Sayuri?
I totally...
I think I missed her.
Hold on.
Will, Arca, Sayuri.
Let's see.
Wait.
Yeah, I see Sayuri.
She's the...
She's the Orca.
Or...
I guess she's Orca.
People were comparing her to an Orca.
Wait.
Who's the...
Oh, Karen.
Pink-haired twin tails.
Wait.
Karen.
Oh, yes!
I did see her!
My feed was... I forgot her name.
Oops.
My feed was...
I didn't even clock that she was Jedi.
I've seen a million arts of her as well.
Oh, my God.
She's so cute.
Yes, I have seen her.
I have seen her.
You're right.
It's funny because her name is Kaden, Karen.
And then you have Kaden.
Very confusing.
Yeah, the new girls are so cute in Blue Archive!
See them in six months.
Okay, wait, that might be it.
We might have enough.
Oh, advance research.
No, I need one more!
one more.
Also, we have some food here?
That's not what I meant to do.
We can't... Anybody hungry?
Ugh.
So many characters with similar names in Blue Archive.
I think that's just...
Sometimes the nature of games when you have so many
characters.
In general, you know, unfortunately.
Where are you?
Oh.
You're resting Please, I just need one more piece!
Please, I just need one more!
Do it.
No!
Wait.
Do it.
Come on, come on.
Yes!
Go, my fox.
Yes, yes!
He's not as good, I think, but that's okay.
You might have a better fire, guy.
We should check.
I think that's key.
I think our guy is pretty good, but...
What the?
Why am I on fire?
Oh, he's three.
Let's see.
Sort.
Fire.
Oh, wait.
Sort.
Kindling.
Blaze Howl is five!
Oh, good job.
improved furnace blaze howl there we go oh he's ginormous
he's so huge that's the thing about this game is like you
get the better pals but they're just increase in size
everything feels so cramped like everything feels so cramped
Ego!
Welcome back, thank you so much.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Um, okay, let's go make our thing.
Yippee!
I'm working.
Oh, wow.
This is gonna take a while, huh?
Help!
With all our powers combined.
we can make the refined metal helm it's skills books yeah
eventually a
tiny max flambelle can beat that guy in kindling any day
though I mean yeah captain planet he's a hero gonna take
pollution down to zero
something something something something is fighting on the
planet side the power is yours I'm gonna take a voicemail
you know what was really terrible the air quality in New
York I was like oh my gosh my voice my throat feels so
scratchy I thought I was getting like you know some point
hey why are you guys abandoning me okay thank you it's so so
bad let's see what's the aqi here yeah
it's okay but it's much less than new york's i got a bit
sicky here scratchy throat no hope you didn't get comic cat
flu i don't think so I think I'm okay It's the worst when
leaving M.I.C.
I legit felt myself breathing better It's, oh my gosh I'm
sure the people that live there like don't realize, or maybe
they do, I don't know, like it's just I mean sure you get
used to it, right?
Mm-hmm.
Three smells in New York.
Exhaust, a reefer sewage.
What's a reefer?
Oh, and Serenade was amazing, so are you.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
That's a weed.
Oh my gosh, we smelled it.
Like, during the show.
Nimmy and I looked at each other, and we were like, Is that
a weed?
We were performing through the weed.
It was so bad.
Yeah, I got a contact high.
I probably did.
140.
Huge upgrade.
Wait, I kind of want to see it, though.
I bet we look cool.
Why is this guy always running?
It scares me a little bit.
Wait.
Edit character outfit?
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
We look so awesome.
Burning the green.
Can't mistake that smell, unfortunately.
I don't know.
I think it smells like skunk.
You guys know what skunk smells like?
I think it smells like a skunk.
We New Yorkers are aware and used to it.
It used to be worse too.
You could see the smog in the 90s.
No way.
Oh, hold on.
Your help is slowly becoming an audio stim for me.
I can't stop saying it this way.
It started as a joke.
And now I can't stop going help.
Help.
I can't help it
I've seen people like playing Kingdom Hearts for the first
time because of like you know all the Kingdom Hearts
announcements and everything and they're like the game
finally i'm gonna try the series and uh why do you only have
one coal
um but it's funny because they're like getting to parts of
the game that are just kingdom hearts i don't know how else
to describe it like uh like get up on the hydra's back
things like that oh oops um let's put everything else oh
wait uh what was it f no f uh bulk storage there we go there
we go
yeah there we go there we go whoa and i've seen people being
like i hate the gummy ship no the gummy ship
hydra's back i had forgotten about stuck in my head get up
on the hydra's back i've never forgotten i've never
forgotten oh never forget never forget let's see i wonder if
we could take on this thing whatever it is let's try it oh
what was that what was that
Oh, hello.
Want to know about the bounties?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I don't care.
I'll check later.
Wait, were you the one?
Oh!
Wait.
Honor of showing me war sect.
Oh, dang it.
I thought you were the one that wanted...
What's his name?
Dang it.
I thought he wanted the flock.
Gobfin.
This guy looks like he would be aggroed, you know?
Well, show me your face.
Yeah, he looks like a guy that would be aggroed, no?
Wait, what level are you?
Oh, I can take you, babe.
Ow!
Ouch!
Oof.
No!
Yippee!
The burbs though.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, whoops.
I don't know why I'm using such...
Stop being so...
Stubborn!
Stupid!
Get in the ball!
Being so stubborn.
There we go.
Gosh.
Cheeky bastard.
It's so funny it says that.
Guy won't go in, cheeky bastard.
Look at them, sleeping soundly.
What are you?
Sealed realm of the sorcerer.
Getting the ball, Shenji.
You can tell they're a British dev.
Are they?
I think they're Japanese.
Wixen oh wait I feel like if I send out eggie he's gonna
kill him you know I think eggie might one kill so I think we
have to do this ourselves guys never mind I'm sending out
eggie eggie just do one hit okay eggie do two hits okay that
might have been kind of early but whatever yeah there the
devs are jabbered I mean, I'm just pretty sure.
Oh, no!
I had a feeling.
I was like, I should do the shot.
No!
Eggie!
Oh, well.
Don't you have the Ring of Mercy equipped?
I do.
But I should have maybe gotten on top of Eggie and done it.
Oh, well.
That's fine.
It's okay.
We'll come back in an hour.
we let's see what other places have we not explored we could
go north northbound a little bit just kind of explore some
new areas new territories there's that up there which looks
like i have not gotten so oh
the thing i have most about power world is that it exists at
all Yeah?
Kind of awesome that it does.
Wait, is that a dungeon?
What are you?
Oh, oh.
Surfing.
I think we have one of those at our base.
Oh, yeah.
Eggies getting heights.
Level 29, we got this.
I like it.
that it exists though you know we need things more things
like this that challenge you know people to not be lazy now
i'm not saying anybody is lazy but you know people really
like this game and if other people that make games similar
want to keep up with the competition you know they should uh
make games what the heck are they oh these are oh they're
the believers
yeah you don't want to stagnate exactly exactly now i know
some people whoa sorry whoa wow i know some people will be
like oh but similar.
I understand that as well.
But...
Whoa.
Whoa, this place is huge!
Digimon needs to step it up.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
What's down there anyway?
Is there like anything usually down there?
Doesn't seem like it.
Oh.
What's that over there?
Grintail.
What are you?
Wait, what are you?
He's taking a little nap.
But he's gonna be mine.
Probably.
Oh, my god.
Oh, oh!
Oh, he's kind of cute.
Hold on.
I'm stealing his scrap first.
Cat bus, pal.
Ow!
Oh my god.
Whoa, he's funky looking.
Oops, I just realized I have the gigosphere.
That's fine.
It's kind of fun looking.
His eyes light up at the moment anyone enters its territory.
This is no figure of speech.
Its eyes literally light up.
That's fine.
How do I get to that tree?
Oh.
Whoa.
Out of this orc?
Wow!
We're fine.
Ooh.
Grapple.
Yeah.
Or I use my hands.
Oh.
What are these?
Oh, there's...
fruits.
Oh, oh interesting.
Okay.
What's this?
Technology.
Yep.
Skill fruit.
Some reason when you say skill fruit, I feel like you're
insulting me.
Like I know you're not saying skill issue, but it just feels
like it.
You know what I mean?
Something about it makes me think that You are insulting me.
A literal skill tree.
I am supposed to be going up, right?
Skill fruit.
All right, what we got in here?
What we got in here?
Ooh, wait, I don't know if I have these fellers.
I don't think I do.
Floppy.
I don't know if I do.
Err...
I'm gonna send out...
Meow cat.
All right, come here.
Skill fruit.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh,
oh, wait, oh, oh, shoot.
Meow cat, come back!
Wait, where is he?
Come on, I can get you, I can get you.
Got
him.
Let's go.
We had one casualty.
That's okay.
Yahoo!
Nice.
Open.
Sesame.
What's this one?
Oh, my carrying capacity!
Let's go.
Give me more tech points.
Yes, please.
Thank you very much.
Yahoo!
Burden potion.
Skill fruit.
Sounds like gamer subs flavor.
If it ever is, just remember to use code boomer.
Thank you!
Whoa.
Good morning, Minto.
Alright, come on, Eggie.
I kind of want to just, like, explore a bit.
There's, like, so much of the land we have yet to explore
still, you know?
So it's kind of fun to just still go around a bit.
Is this a hack?
I'm hacking?
Correct position.
Oh.
Oh, so close.
Oh, oops.
Oops.
first try
grass support whistle I think I have a fire whistle what are
those guys doing down there oh there's a thing over there
too hacking circle makes you want a donut wait what are you
leaf on cute What the?
Cute, cute, cute.
Eggie.
That's what that is.
What the?
Oh, is that panda coming after me?
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, do you get aggroed?
Oh, they do.
Oops.
Uh, don't worry about me.
Nice.
Where are we at?
Oh!
Yeah, I think I saw that watchtower.
nice nice we gotta watch out for these guys i don't really
want to deal with them right now what oh my god please
please i just said i don't want to deal with you okay i
think he's fine i kind of want her though wait uh we'll take
you out we
were too good dang it i didn't think one kill her.
Skylight's her name is so good!
I keep watching the gif of you and Nimmy doing the creeping
dance.
The creeping dance?
Then chugging off the stage.
What's the... Oh yeah, we were creeping.
I was gonna...
Yeah.
We did that.
Oh, I leveled up.
When did I have them?
We're gonna do my health.
Big egg.
Yeah, I think what Makes me not want to do that.
Like, I don't feel so inclined to get the eggs so much.
It's because, like, they take so long, you know?
They take so...
Oh, let's get that up there.
They take so long to be made.
So it's, like, not so fun to have to wait for them.
You know?
It is a free pal.
It is.
Can I make it?
Nope.
they're not supposed to take that long i have been told many
a times trust me i have been told not even not once not even
twice oh what's this something up there hmm
They're so cute.
We'll go up the long way for exploration sake.
Oh, you know what?
Never mind.
Wah.
Dungeon!
Nice.
Oh!
Elizabeth!
We might.
Be able to.
The bee guards can blow you up like creepers.
Oh, really?
I think we can get this one in, though.
Mountain stream grotto.
Let's go in.
But I also want to get the fast travel just in case first.
You know.
Oh.
Oh, right.
Nice.
Meow cat!
Come on out.
We got a lot of this guy though.
We just get the big guy.
We'll just go after the big guy.
Meow cat!
Be careful!
He's tough.
Maybe I can...
Not yet.
Oh wait, I'm scared.
Now.
Meowcat, be careful!
Maybe I go to the Gigaspher.
I think, though, if I get this guy...
Whoop, whoop, whoop!
Come on!
It might...
put me to the five guys I need.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Meowcat going at it.
Yeah.
YAHOO!
It did!
We got it, we got the effigy.
Nice.
Five guys mentioned.
Oh yeah.
Oh, my inventory is full!
Uh oh.
Um, eat those.
Oops.
Wait, eat this.
Eat this instead.
It's better for you.
Oh, my metal helm.
I'm just gonna discard it.
I'm also going to replace my gun with the Cajun fries fries
Five guys Orger
Stop you guys Stop I haven't had much to eat today Can I get
a happy birthday?
Guardian Gazeable Happy birthday I hope they are not trying
times for you.
I hope they are very fun times.
I hope they are so fun.
Do I have a cinema?
Oh, I have, I have, I have.
We'll send out Eggie.
Eggie might kill them, though.
Hey, hey.
Go kill him.
Go kill him!
Wow!
Maybe I...
Sword!
I gotta
watch the other guy though.
Uh...
Sure.
Oh!
No way!
How did that not do it?
Yippee!
Ow gosh!
Oh my gosh.
Stop!
Stop it!
You're so annoying!
Got the other guy at least.
Thank you so much for the...
What if I get dead?
Yeah, we caught the boss version at least.
My goodness!
Gracious.
Wait, where am I going?
Oh, this way.
Didn't even break a sweat.
Yeah, didn't even do that at all.
Everything was totally fine and chill the whole time.
Let's see.
What can we get rid of?
We can get rid of some fiber.
We can get rid of the one wood and the bone.
That's fine.
Pick up the book.
I'm working on a few my...
Sorry, if you heard that that was my phone.
My new phone, I will not drop.
Not the one fiber.
I got a food item.
But I don't have enough slots.
I guess I could, like, just eat it on the spot.
Eat it.
Breaking on a few Minecraft projects at the moment.
I'm very happy with some.
Is there a style in particular that you like?
That sounds so cool.
But I don't know what you mean.
By...
style
food in right column third row I have more
cube style yeah I like when my this this is not food this is
for a quest
I'm nervous let's go
there's no wait there's just this one isn't that the one all
the way up there even though we can take her there's three
two guards and three guards and her it's a little
frightening oh my gosh there's even more down here why are
there so many let's get back let's go up there oh I thought
I was gonna land on him and then he would attack me oh shoot
oh my gosh why is this place so infested eggy is overpowered
you think so why are there so many believers here
please it just whoa my god
eggy eggy we have to make it up eggy we have to make it up
Holy cow.
Do the mood!
Yeah, ho ho ho.
Truly a goofy moment.
Do you want me to doubt you again?
I could do that.
That would give me maybe a little bit of a...
You know, like, oh, no.
If you doubt me, that makes me want to win even more
scenarios.
right grab this squirrel wow we can see so much from up here
wow fly
me to the mood starts playing wow what's that over there on
the frozen area we haven't even touched that yet crazy the
snap is ginormous Oh, yeah, what is this?
Holy cow.
Whoa.
We barely touched the map at all.
Look at all of this.
I just can't get over how huge this game is.
Me, you and me.
Two.
Yeah.
Me neither.
It's like actually humongous.
How much longer is the server running?
Oh my gosh.
This made my stomach drop.
Honestly?
Wait, can I land on him?
Oh, dang it.
Oh.
Nice.
Mine.
Doki said for as long as people want to keep playing.
I wasn't sure if she said like a...
Something a month or something.
I'm just going to do a Megasphere.
Oh, come on.
Alright, let's ignore this guy.
Ouch.
Wait, is it her?
No.
Hmm.
The scary thing is, if I don't beat this bee lady, the queen
bee, I cannot very easily, like, I can teleport here, but I
cannot very easily get back to, you know, to that spot.
Oh, nice.
Because she is so, I wouldn't have any of my pals, you know.
I mean, I guess I could borrow a pal to, like...
Wait, where'd that go?
Oh, I'm tripped.
I saw, or I thought I saw...
There, that one?
Maybe this one I saw?
Must be.
I could always, like, have one and use it for, I guess, I
don't know.
You know what I mean.
It's just a little tougher.
Oh, these guys are...
These guys are mean.
I'll remember.
They're mean.
Sacred Realm.
Now see here, we're right next to one.
So it's a little bit easier.
It's a little bit easier.
So I think we'll take it.
Tarantris.
I still gotta get that.
Wait, where was she?
35.
We might be able to do it now.
Might be able to do it now.
I think there's a way to transfer.
for the save file if the server ever goes down.
That'd be awesome.
I think there is, oh, Lunaris.
All right.
Oh, Meowcat, go!
Oh, Meowcat might be overpowered.
Oh, cheeky bastard.
Come on.
Yeah!
Let's go.
It can control, oh, I've missed the description.
Lunaris I think might be able to do Makes your sphere
homing?
Wait, that's crazy!
Lunaris has a straight up upgrade to Catava.
More expanded carrying capacity and it makes your spheres
homing.
Well?
Eggie, take me home!
Eggie!
roads oh eggy what are you doing to me eggy I don't like
this eggy I'm uncomfortable oh there we go to the place I
belong what's up there wow this looks this looks crazy hold
on I gotta check this out this looks crazy on the map is it
this way yeah why does it look so dark oh oh
Nice.
Wish Virginia.
Time to report Egy to HR.
No!
Egy wouldn't do that!
Egy!
No!
Let's go back to base and drop some stuff off.
Then it's time to have the tarantula lady revengeance.
And also, I guess it's time to say goodbye to Cativa
everybody where we now have lunaris lunaris spheres homin on
pals whoa plus she kind of looks like drossel from fireball
and that appeals to me oh i'm sorry he my lunaris is a is a
guy i'm gonna change it i'm gonna get the surgery table so I
can name you Drossel.
That was her name.
You remember?
Did anyone else?
Did anyone else watch Fireball?
So good.
See, hold on.
Can I search?
Like...
Oh, here, here.
Oh, my God!
Yes.
I've only seen clips but it looks really fun You should
watch it because the episodes are like They're mini
episodes, right?
They're like five minutes long They're super They're super
short Very easy series to watch Also I'm noticing a bit of a
Like a color scheme In our party Do you guys know I like
blue and purple Fox sparks No, I love Fox sparks Yeah, you
can blast right through it in a day Yeah, exactly, exactly
And it's like witty It's just a fun Fun series
My tab just crashed You guys I have, I saw it, I just saw my
other tab Which reminded me Did you guys see Konami
announced Metal Gear pet products.
Like, I can get a love pack box for my cat!
Need, need, need, need, need, need, need, need, need.
I've never needed anything more.
I've never needed anything more!
And you can get, like, a little barrel that they can hide
in.
And they had something else.
Like, a little exclamation point, like, cat toy thing.
it's so cute it's so cute
hold on let me get the picture out the tab need yes me too
look at this it's so oh my gosh look at this look at this
look look with your eyes look with your eyes if you are a
cat owner and also metal gear Heitz is kind of crazy.
It's a scratch pad.
It's so cute.
Oh, it's so cute.
I need the love pack.
I need like 10 of them.
How much would it cost?
I don't know.
Let's see if they set a price.
It says fans.
Okay, so they're gonna have it at a cat con.
2026 in Pasadena Convention Center in California from
October 10th to 11th.
But fans not in attendance can still purchase...
Ah!
Oh, what was that?
Someone is plotting to raid my...
Gosh, dang it.
Let's scare the heck out of me.
You can buy it on the Konami Gear Shop.
Only during the event.
There's no prize.
That's scary.
Konami partnered with Cat Curtis and her one-eared Cat Uno.
I don't know that cat.
Five million follower cat influencer.
Holy cow.
Yeah.
I demand you to go to that con me, though.
I can't.
I can't, unfortunately.
That's so much travel.
So much travel.
Okay.
guy let's get this over with yeah actually i'm gonna go to
sleep first
will they attack me in my sleep
yeah i'll order it i will order it i will order it for sure
100 i'm gonna put it in my calendar even
wait where's the guy that asks if oh there he is The
negotiator.
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
Alright, team.
Heard of Violet Wild Pals!
Incoming!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Eggie, no, it's not time for logging.
Eggie, it's not time for logging.
I gotta go capture some pals.
No!
Please!
I just got here!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Everything all happened all I want.
The wave has been cleared.
Okay, maybe?
Cognito is just up there.
Oh, it's these guys!
Nice!
Yay!
Good job, team!
Good job, team.
Everybody alive up here?
Wow, minimal casualties.
Very, very good job.
Oh, my inventory's full.
I didn't get any of these guys, though, sadly.
What is that?
You know, I've never gone this way.
Yeah.
I've never gone this way before.
Alright, let's go put some stuff away.
Alrighty.
Time for an adventure.
Oh, I did not...
Okay, good, good.
Let's do...
Stow everything, I guess?
Yeah, stow, stow, stow, yes.
Nice.
Gotta get a swimming pal.
Oh, I've got a swimming pal.
Don't you worry.
Oh, I didn't even realize I had that.
And this.
Okay, we'll use that on...
Okay.
Very good.
Let's use this.
Oh, oh, that's right.
I can't use it in PvP.
Let's use this on Lunarous Drossil.
Go in there.
Yeah, Chill It's time to shine again.
Chill It hasn't seen the sun in weeks.
Chill it.
It's okay.
And your very cute outfit even.
Oh, come here.
I know I was going to go get that spider lady, but we'll get
her in a bit.
And I have unused stats.
Let's do my stamina.
Nice.
Alright, chill it.
Let's head to that island.
Meow.
Chilla is so cute.
Big fan.
It's not that far away, right?
Probably.
Oh, nope.
What's that?
Oh, wait.
That's where we started, though.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
All right.
Almost there.
Our stamina is a half.
Don't worry.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
We're almost there!
Okay.
We got this.
Yeah.
Sunlit Isle.
Awesome.
Ooh.
It's so beechy here.
What are these?
Fincider.
Oh, wait.
They're so cute.
They're just like a little guy in there.
They're like a little guy disguised.
Oh, hello.
laid-back angler
speak to me talk
perfect weather for fishing huh but you wouldn't know it I
haven't had a single bite all day the jelliet I've been
trying to catch just won't take the bait jelliet meat is so
firm and chewy I can't get enough of it say if you catch one
would you share a bite of the meat with me just thinking
about it makes my mouth drool
he's hitting them he's hitting them and then he's gonna eat
me oh my wait these guys are like super low level maybe they
expect you to come here much earlier on who was whistling at
me like that wait what is this
oh okay
they're calling me sexy or something
Nice.
It looks like something is peeking out from inside a
costume, but if you reach inside, there's nothing there.
In fact, you keep reaching deeper and deeper.
Perhaps the universe itself lies within.
Okay.
Whoa.
All right, Finn.
Sider.
Finn.
I keep wanting to call him a finster.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
I think I'm capturing them.
I haven't really been checking.
Recess?
That's right!
Her name was a Miss Finster, wasn't it?
That's funny.
I like when there's a lot of them all real close together
like this, so I can...
They're not much around here, huh?
Not even over here.
but yeah so I can just like get five immediately yeah we
just wipe them all out it's great mother mother base mother
base that's weapon bosses literally
eradicate hidden on the map hidden on the map.
Guys, I'm starting to get a little hungry, so let's go take
out that spider lady.
Then I might call it.
I'm not gonna indulge this guy in his sick depravity of
hunger for jellies.
Me too, though.
I'm also hungry for jellies.
But be careful, don't Don't eat those jellies before you go
on a plane because you might poop yourself.
Just fair warning.
Hasn't happened to me.
I feel like it could happen to somebody.
Anybody.
Alright.
This pretty little lady over here.
I mean the cognac jellies.
They are a natural laxative.
Apparently jellyfish tastes weird.
That was like a popular thing I guess in Japan.
though is jellyfish okay don't quite remember where she was
up here they're like 99% fiber yeah yeah they're quite
fibrous oh this is our other base oh my gosh I forgot I
could have just teleported here wait awesome wait this This
is awesome.
Wait, this is great.
This is great news.
Moniac also helps oxalate stones form.
Wait, what?
So be safe.
Are you saying that I might get kidney stones from eating
too many jellies?
I once had, they were my, like, I love jellies.
I love the cognac jellies.
And one time I bought like 10 of them.
And I tried to take them on the plane.
this is a liquid.
I was like, no, it's jelly.
They were like, you can't take this.
Like, through TSA.
The Japanese form of TSA.
I was like, well, well, what do I do?
And they were like, well, you could, you can, um, throw them
away or, or something.
I was like, can I eat them?
And they were like, yeah.
And so I just stood there in front of them and I was just
sucking on these jellies.
Like 10 of them.
Oh.
I pressed the wrong button!
We're
fine.
Meow cat.
Let's go!
Oh, damn it.
I didn't get any time.
Meow cat, too strong.
Oh, shoot.
Help me, meow cat!
Meow cat!
She will be mine.
Meowcat ate an omelet.
Very good.
The helmet does help a lot, doesn't it?
No.
Just a little bit more.
I'm going to try again.
Yeah!
Extremely sticky and clingy.
The more it's resisted, the more tenacious it becomes.
Such as its personality.
Oh, we didn't get these two, but that's okay.
Yay!
Yeah!
The revenge was so...
Sweet!
Tarantris is one of the best mobility pals and it's also
really hot.
I agree!
Yippee!
Thank you, Meowcat!
Thank you, Meowcat.
Why does my horse want to log so bad?
Oh, I don't have this guy.
Wrong guy.
Oh wait.
Oh geez.
Oh don't kill that guy.
Oh shoot.
There we go.
Maybe I'll grab him then.
Aw dang it.
Oh no!
Oh I got him.
I got him.
Cool.
Oh we missed out on one though.
That's sad.
Nice boss.
First kill boss.
Thank you!
I kind of want her hanging out with me.
I mean him.
Sorry.
I'm being so insensitive.
I'm hips though.
I'm gonna name you, Raiden.
Come on, Raiden.
Let's go.
Back home.
Where was the thing?
That was this way, Winno.
Map, map, map.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You two bodies, babe.
like Mewtwo or...
You know what I mean?
Oh, come on.
Yeah, take that guy out.
Yeah, take a boat.
I'll get him.
Hey!
Yeah, you don't block my sphere!
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
He regretted that.
Thank you, Ryden.
Oh my god!
Sorry.
I got a little flustered looking at him.
It's been great to watch you stream again, Vintobo.
I hope whatever food you get is yummy.
Thank you, Lou.
Aye.
Mmm.
I know I just came from Japan, but I kind of went sushi.
Don't lose your cool, Minto.
Sorry, I'm cool.
I'm cool.
Don't embarrass me in front of Ryden, you guys.
I'm cool Is everybody here still suffering and sad And
depressed and Right at about two seconds from jumping off
the cliff Yes
Slopesville Oh my gosh They look so Look at he's barely Oh
my god This is so sad Matarikon What have you done He's the
poor pals is the poor pals literally me she's like created
this horrible these horrible conditions and then left it's
just so sad it's just so sad i'm gonna go get that and then
we'll call it quit
I'm too addicted to this game you guys I can't stop playing
I can't stop playing this is the improved conditions too no
it's not don't lie don't lie all right I'm gonna grab that
one too I don't even notice that was over there until I saw
from way up above awesome we're exploring so much and we're
getting so many things and we are going around the world
world traveler oh there's only one
oh Oh, it's out.
Did I get you?
Oh.
Come on.
Nice.
Sulfur.
Wait, where you see that?
Oh, there's more.
That's okay.
No, I have a goal.
I have a goal.
Sorry.
I'm getting...
I'm getting lost in the sauce.
I hear somebody flying.
Who needs a flying pal when you have...
Eggie, everybody.
Give it up for Eggie!
Yeah.
Oh, what is that over there?
That's a big statue.
You see that?
Right, that thing?
Wait, I've been there before.
Just kidding.
I took that thing down.
I'm silly, sorry.
Show me the world.
It's the world and the world around you.
Shining, shimmering, splendid.
Tell me, princess.
When did you last?
Let your heart decide.
I can open your mind.
I take you wonder by wonder Over sideways and under On a
magic carpet ride A whole new world A hundred places to see
No one can tell us no Kill Herbal Kill him You live today Oh
Can't go back to where I used to be Ouch!
Ouch!
Every turn of surprise Every moment read letter Oh, they go
everywhere Let me share this killer A new world with you A
whole new world A whole new world That's where we'll be
That's where we'll be
Wait, how do I get home?
I...
Let's go get this thing.
Come here, Eggie.
Eggie, Eggie, come.
Eggie, come here.
Eggie!
Eggie, stop looking at me like that.
Eggie, come here.
Let me ride you.
Eggie!
listen to me.
Oh my gosh.
It was like, uh...
Hmm?
Oh, dang it.
I went the wrong way.
Eggie, can you swim?
Eggie's got a lock in.
Eggie questioning the morality of your recent actions.
Eki contributed.
Eki cannot say anything to me.
Eki has no moral grounds to judge me on.
I'm on the island side.
Yay!
Thank you guys for more POW world!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm sorry, I'm basically a POW world streamer at this point.
I'm basically a power world streamer at this point but i had
so much fun and i hope you guys did too i hope i hope i hope
thank you for the stream welcome home thank you thank you i
had so much fun it was a lot of fun i hope you guys had fun
too and i will catch you next time whatever whatever Uh, so
nice having you bas-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-boss.
We miss you so much.
My name's Thakur!
Don't go, thank you for the peek!
So happy to see you on stream again.
Skylight's here, and if it's amazing, we'll still miss you
lots.
Hope you eat much, much yummy food and have an amazing
night.
And please see a doctor.
I will.
Meow cat sends love.
I love Meow cat.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you for the silver chance, Alt-Zero!
Thank you, everybody.
Why is the stream labs working?
Oh, no!
I'm sorry.
Girl.
How dare.
Okairee.
Thank you guys!
Otsumito!
So nice to have you back with you!
Thank you!
Otsumito everybody!
Thank you so much for the warm, warm, warm, warm, warm,
warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, warm,
welcome back!
Made a home safe.
Oh, Kaini!
Love all you've been doing and looking forward to board!
Thank you!
Miss you so much!
I miss you guys so much!
Did you look at her?
Thank you so much, pink!
Oh, it's a bito!
Oh, it's a bito.
Bye-bye.
See you.
Eat the next time.
I've been Uncle Eggie for the past year.
Thank you.
That's so funny.
Bye-bye.